même nombre de courses par jour l'avait
en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé ya qu un 5/6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivée la
concurrente bb&t gros gros choc d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé les 20000 à
45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
[Musique]
un millier de soignons soldats et autres
travailleurs dits essentiels invité à la
maison blanche les etats-unis ils
célèbrent ce dimanche leur fête
nationale
l'occasion pour joe biden de marquer le
retour de l'amérique selon ses mots le
président américain qui s'était fixé
pour cette date l'objectif de 70% en
adultes vaccinés contre coville objectif
manqué ils réclament la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants prg avant le
début du mois de septembre une centaine
de médecins demandent au gouvernement
français de prendre cette mesure pour
éviter une quatrième vague mesures
effectives en italie sous peine d'être
suspendu de son poste ou privés de
salaire 300 soigne aux italiens viennent
de déposer un recours pour protester
[Musique]
les rebelles du tigre et acceptent le
principe d'un cessez le feu mais pose
des conditions qu'ils demandent
notamment le retrait des forces entre
elles qui soutiennent l'armée régulière
ainsi que la restauration des autorités
de la région
le tigre est le théâtre de combats
depuis que le premier ministre éthiopien
a lancé une opération militaire pour
renverser le gouvernement local
le nude alerte sur la situation
humanitaire plus de quatre cent mille
personnes ont déjà franchi le seuil de
la famille
[Musique]
il
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les américains
en fait donc ce 4 juillet l'anniversaire
de la déclaration d'indépendance de leur
pays vis-à-vis de la grande-bretagne
joe biden accueille pour l'occasion un
millier d'invités à la maison blanche
une journée que le président américain
souhaite placer sous le signe du retour
à la normale pour les états unis
on retrouve tout de suite à washington
d'être un correspondant thomas bonnin
bonjour thomas joe biden avait fait ce 4
juillet un cap il s'était fixé des
objectifs chiffrés en termes de
vaccination antico vide mais le
président américain même s'il se montre
optimiste doit constater son échec
absolument c'est un échec pour joe biden
et nous avons un petit problème de
connexion avec thomas bonne et on va
tout de suite retrouvé notre invité
douglas y est professeur de droit
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france on s'en souvient de
ces festivités un minima l'année
dernière en raison de la pandémie en ans
plus tard elle les états unis ont changé
de président au delà de l'indépendance
les américains célèbrent aujourd'hui une
forme de retour à la normale tous les
dieux si le nord c'est son pandémie mais
avec plein de mini rien d'étonnant de
rassembler donini l'yonne ensemble
pendant le qu'ovide donc on a maintenant
des métriques leduc l'un comme dans
l'autre on a fait des grandes réunions
dans nos maisons granges les démocrates
se plaindre et maintenant il semble
comme joe boyd fait la même chose c'est
tout et eros irresponsable dans tout les
états unis un homme violent qui s'étend
partout et on est premiers obligé de
porter des masques aux mains des gens
qui refusent d'être vaccinés oui s'ils
ont pour devoir de célébrer
l'indépendance des états unis
mais halak ou des millions de vies et
dans l'esprit des américains malgré
cette pandémie toujours très présentes
vous le rappelle ce que l'heure est à la
fête
au plan sanitaire on le rappelle donc à
joe biden a donc échoué à atteindre cet
objectif pour ce 4 juillet d'une
première dose administrée à 70% de la
population adulte le nombre de nouveaux
cas de vide ne baisse plus depuis la mi
juin puis vous le rappeliez le vire le
variant delta se propage quel est votre
regard sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par joe biden aujourd'hui dont
la frite donald trump
oui ok on a deux éléments d'abord si on
regarde les sondages une majorité à peu
près 60 4
pour cent des américains approuvent de
lagence de l'administration bayonne de
kobe mais on a aussi les deuxième chose
que sur l'objectif de 70% ces chiffrés
et il y avait une date et on a dépassé
sa date est donc le vaincre le pain de
mie c'est central aux stratégies jo by
day et donc c'est un échec que ce date
c'est une problème a souvent parce que
ça veut dire comme un problème vacciner
les populations mais aussi parce que ça
montre comme les promesses ne sont pas
tenues et et dans un programme cinq
chalets qui vivent c'est un peu avec lui
de donner 30
il a bien dû beaucoup de confiance on ne
livrait pas son projet et si les
démocrates ne réussit pas à 70% en mois
de août
maintenant c'est le prognostic si ça
continue ou moins de 70 pressante en
septembre en octobre
ça va ça pourrait dire que les états
unis n'ont pas imité du troupeau un de
minetti exigé pour arrêter le pain de
mie et après ça c'est nouvelle vague
avec le data au delà de ce bilan
sanitaire plus largement quel bilan est
ce que vous dressez après six mois de
joe biden
ouais bien sûr je suis un peu probable
parce qu'un pour moi les optiques à
l'étranger est des états unis à la fed
de règles soient comme meken réside
entre brock
mais si on regarde les sondages il était
stable entre 52% et 56% des vainqueurs
dans les sondages depuis le début
soutient d'oberrieden penser un peu plus
que le moitié de population pense qu'il
fait de bien mais ça veut dire aussi que
presque la moitié de la population ne
sont pas contents et comme on regarde
proches ces sondages ses partisans 90%
des démocrates
m
sur base des faits et 18% entre
républicaine donc maintenant le
pronostic de biting et bien sûr par
l'opposition républicaine comme baissé
et il faut éliminer ce perspective avec
les registres à sion bipartisans va
essayer avec le programme fasttrack
sommairement des blocages et des coloris
dans les primaires pour la prochaine
électorale prochaine cycle les
législatives
on va voir ce division augmente et
l'impossibilité d'accomplir les grands
programmes est ce que vous direz que joe
biden a toutefois réussi à apaiser
certaines tensions souvient de ces
manifestations il ya un an contre le
racisme dans la foulée de la mort de
l'afro-américain de georges frêche
n'était levante femme est 2020 oui je
pense que comme un nouveau signe bolik
de président des états unis
il a épuisé les esprits d'abord avec les
nominations de gamme la grèce comme son
vice présidente et les nominations de
nouvelle ministre de défense un homme
noir indienne américaines comme son
ministère de l'intérieur donc il a fait
beaucoup de symbolisme mais les choses
probablement qu'ils aient joué en
ferrain de l'épier semant le social sur
la question raciale
c'est l inculpation de le policier qui a
tué
ça c'était très important même si l'on
sacrifie sienne individus pour créer des
pays les fêtes c'est qu'on n'a plus des
grandes manifestations
blacklight semaine et ça donne un moment
pour réflexion et pour un point mais
diop a été attribué à faire dans le
racisme dans les polices parce que plus
que 90% des polices aux états unis sont
sous le contrôle des états et pas sur le
confort du gouvernement fédéral qui
explique il a échoué jusque là à mettre
en place des réformes à la fois sur la
police ou encore l'immigration
oui ce sont deux fois moi je croyais pas
qu'il a
jamais réussi avec l'immigration parce
qu'il a des priorités et il a dépensé
son capital politique sur le plan des
imf stocks ce qui va avoir une éthique
économique importante
donc je ne crois pas comment le grand
réforme l'immigration qui était promis
pour la réforme de la prise ces hold
control de white case de washington il a
proposé par son ministère son père tony
john rossant son ministère de justice
un certain nombre de réformes qui
pourraient aider un peu dans la
criminalité mais le fond' il faut faire
au niveau des états et ça c'est au le
contrôle de président dans le système
fédéral
donc nos nids pour l'immigration ni pour
la réforme de police pas de n'a pas
réussi il a mis son capital politique
sur le programme fait stocks 1,2 ou
triangle d'or merci beaucoup
regarde bien fait je rappelle que cette
professeur de droit spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines et on en
parlait à l'instant il est déjà admis
non dans plusieurs pays le varions delta
continue sa course un peu partout dans
le monde
cette souche très contagieuse en
provenance d'inde est à l'origine d'un
nouveau record de contamination en
russie en france elle représente environ
20% des cas de vide
les spécialistes redoutent une quatrième
vague en europe
tour d'horizon avec maxime abers cette
semaine ce devait être le dernier des
quatre actes du déconfinement en france
dans les landes le variant delta on a
décidé autrement
ici la nouvelle forme du virus
représente désormais 45% des tests
positifs contre 25 sur tout le
territoire entre le 26 et le 30 juin
ce taux a même grimpé à 81,5 % le
département le plus touché a donc décidé
de prolonger les mesures sanitaires et
d'autres départements comme le var ont
suivi le variant delta et surtout dans
le département des landes
mais on voit que ce qui se passe dans
les landes va se passer dans toute la
région et dans toute la france
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
aujourd'hui c'est que personne n'y
échappera
de quoi relancer la question de la
vaccination obligatoire depuis plus d'un
mois
l'académie nationale de médecine et le
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale milite pour une obligation de
vaccination dans certaines professions
comme les soignants ailleurs en europe
la situation est tout aussi inquiétante
au portugal dès ce vendredi de nouvelles
restrictions sont entrées en vigueur
pour 45 communes dont porto et la
capitale lisbonne
un couvre-feu de 23h à 5h du matin
instaurée par le gouvernement et qui
concerne près d'un portugais sur 2 ce
samedi l'armée a même été appelé en
renfort pour soutenir la campagne de
vaccination
de l'autre côté de l'europe depuis la mi
juin déjà confrontée elle aussi à la
multiplication de la souche l 452 m
la russie est dans l'oeil du cyclone un
dernier décompte fait état ce dimanche 2
663 morts en vingt-quatre avant cela
moscou avait enregistré pendant cinq
jours d'affilée des records de décès la
capitale russe est le principal foyer de
contamination dans le pays
la campagne de vaccination n'a attiré
que 23,6 millions d'habitants sur les
146 que compte le pays
pourtant vladimir poutine se veut
confiant et mis sur le pass sanitaires
et le vaccin qui pourrait devenir
obligatoire dans certaines régions les
décisions des administrations des dix
régions
justement cette fonction d'éviter le
confinement puisque le confinement c'est
ce sont les gens qui restent sans
salaire ce sont les banqueroutes des pme
et la baisse des revenus des gens alors
pour l'éviter dans certaines régions on
prévoit la vaccination obligatoire
cette nouvelle souche du virus
viendra largement majoritaire dans l'ue
estime l'agencé européenne des maladies
alors la bonne nouvelle nous viendra
peut-être d'outre-manche en effet des
données provenant du royaume uni sont
rassurantes
le variant delta y représentent 95% des
cas séquencée au mois de juin
pourtant les hôpitaux ne se remplissent
pas comme lors de la deuxième vague
champion de la vaccination en europe
le pays se veut rassurant les deux doses
de vaccin sont efficaces à 90% pour
prévenir les hospitalisations à jean
castex recevra à partir de demain les
chefs de file du parlement et des élus
locaux pour aborder la question de
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants une
centaine de médecins milite en sa faveur
il demande la mise en application de
cette mesure avant le début du mois de
septembre
ils ont publié une tribune en ce sens
dans le journal du dimanche
parmi les signataires le chef du service
réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière
nommé gardanne le soignant est une
personne qui a décidé d'apporter des
soins aux personnes fragiles malades qui
confient leur santé en toute sécurité et
donc effectivement il n'est pas
concevable que nous puissions
transmettent une pathologie grave
potentiellement dans l en pratique il
est probable que une étape intermédiaire
serait de réaffecter cette personne
soignante vers des tâches
administratives ou logistique sans
contact direct avec les patients
les sanctions seront aussi à décider en
fonction du nombre de personnels ne
souhaitant pas malgré tout être vaccinés
car comme vous le savez à l'hôpital
public nous manquons de personnel
soignant
évidemment il ne faudrait pas qu'en
retirant un certain nombre de personnels
on se retrouve dans la difficulté en
italie la vaccination des trayons est
obligatoire depuis le mois d'avril 98 %
des professionnels de santé ont reçu au
moins une injection antico vide dans le
pays en cas de manquement le
contrevenant s'ils travaillent au
contact du public est affecté dans un
autre service ou bien suspendu sans
solde
si l'employeur n'a pas de nouvelles
tâches à lui proposer 300 toiles aux
italiens ont saisi la justice pour
protester ils réclament la levée de
l'obligation de se faire vacciner
médecins urgentistes en italie ou
berthod giovannini a réagi sur notre
antenne écoutez donc il ya de vous les
problématiques de démarches elle se la
démarche démocratique ça ce qui ne peut
pas me poser une seule catégorie
professionnelle décès vacciner donc
d'abord cette signature a ouvert une
discussion sur le budget obligatoire les
vaccins pour leurs nationaux et de
l'autre il ya le libre choix des
traitements qui est in italy c'est un
des piliers de la démocratie et de la
médecine
donc c'est toujours compliqué il faut
dire aussi que la l'autre problématique
enitalie une pèlerine pas choisir avec
quel d'accès vacciner on s'est posés par
l'état donc chaque personne les vaccins
sur lequel tant de vaccination
objectif pour le rassemblement national
la présidentielle l'an prochain
le parti était réuni en congrès a permis
à perpignan tout ce week-end sans
surprise marine le pen a été réélu à sa
tête pour un quatrième mandat après
l'échec aux régionales elle s'est dite
extrêmement combative et déterminée pas
du tout découragé pour 2022 elle sera
remplacé par jordan bardella le ton de
la présidentielle lui qui a été désigné
le premier vice président du fn marine
le pen a tenu un discours dans l'après
midi
je vous propose de l'écouter ici ne
croyons pas en une quelconque stratégie
providentialiste qui est celle des âmes
fataliste c'est laisser aller qui
voudrait qu'il suffit de se faire porter
par les évènements compter sur la chance
ou peut-être même sur le hasard pour
gagner nous savons l'expérience nous
l'enseignent que rien ne s'accomplira
sans effort sans cohésion et surtout
sans cohérence
nous savons que l'histoire ne se subit
pas mais qu'elle s'écrit jour après jour
patiemment et pour nous à qui on ne
pardonne rien bien souvent dans
l'adversité victoire surtout contre eux
tout un système coalisés se bâtit se
construit se conquiert et cette victoire
je vous le dis mes amis cette victoire
nous allons la chercher toujours en
france militants et organisations se
sont rassemblés en soutien ou irak
manifestation ce dimanche à paris de la
diaspora algérienne
la date coïncide avec le 59e
anniversaire de la fête de
l'indépendance en algérie
après l'interdiction de 4e marche en
raison d'un risque d'atteinte à l'ordre
public la préfecture de paris a autorisé
un rassemblement cet après midi défilé
de la place de la république à la place
de la nation une victoire symbolique
pour les organisateurs côté manifestants
un seul mot d'ordre l'arrêt de la
répression par les autorités algériennes
pour nous c'est important de rappeler
qu'on a gagné que le peuple algérien a
battu une des grandes d un des grandes
colons qui s'appelle la france et que
malheureusement petit à petit cette
indépendance a été grignotée et qui a
été remplacé par une dictature le
pouvoir au lieu de répondre aux
aspirations du peuple par l'application
de l'article s'était vite à savoir le
respect de la souveraineté populaire
il répond par l'article 87 à savoir
incriminés tout acte politique
les prisons en algérie croupissent
d'innocents les richesses sont dilapidés
la souveraineté est compromise
le territoire est vendu on est au
protectorat de la france et d'autres
pays
le peuple algérien veut se réapproprier
son pays
toujours d'un dans la revendication
d'une nouvelle algérie qui n'a jerry's
démocratique réellement démocratique et
surtout la libération de tous les
détenus
près d'une semaine après que le
gouvernement éthiopien a proclamé un
cessez le feu unilatéral aux tigres et
les rebelles disent aujourd'hui acceptée
principe mais sous conditions des
conditions qui rendent difficile sa
normalisation
ils demandent entre autres le retrait
des forces érythréenne qui soutiennent
l'armée régulière ainsi que la
restauration des autorités de leur
région
et depuis le mois de novembre
s'affrontent le gouvernement fédéral est
un groupe rebelle du nord du pays et le
rapport de force semble aujourd'hui
fonds versés hélène masquelier machette
et kalachnikov levé en signe de victoire
la population applaudi les combattants
rebelles drapeau rouge et jaune symbole
de la région du tigré sont déployées les
forces de défense tigréenne ont bien
repris le contrôle de la capitale
régionale mais qu'elle est les
combattants rebelles ont surpris les
forces gouvernementales ce lundi en
attaquant ce bastion aux mains de
l'armée fédérale depuis sept mois
une victoire rebelles à laquelle addis
abeba n'a que faiblement réagi avec
l'annoncé d'un cessez-le-feu unilatéral
pis la décision de suspendre les
hostilités a été prise unilatéralement
de notre côté mais bien sûr pour mettre
pleinement en oeuvre un cessez le feu il
faut être deux comme au tango c'est à la
partie adverse de réagir pour permettre
la mise en oeuvre effective du cessez le
feu
d'abord qualifié de blague par un porte
parole des forces rebelles
les combattants tigréens ont finalement
accepté ce dimanche le principe d'un
cessez le feu mais sous conditions ils
demandent notamment le retrait des
forces érythréenne et amara qui
soutiennent l'armée éthiopienne
ils veulent aussi que le premier
ministre éthiopien habib ahmed rendent
des comptes et réclame la création d'un
organe indépendant par l'onu pour
enquêter sur les crimes commis pendant
le conflit
autre condition la distribution sans
entrave de l'aide humanitaire selon
l'onu
plus de 400 mille personnes dans la
région font face à la famine
employé comme arme de guerre
la population est privée de ses terres
ou empêchait de cultiver tandis que
l'aide humanitaire peine à être
acheminée beaucoup soupçonnent addis
abeba de mettre en place un blocus dans
la région ce jeudi encore un pont voie
stratégique d'approvisionnement par où
transite une grande partie de l'aide
humanitaire a été détruit un acte
attribué aux forces gouvernementales
ce don addis abeba se défend jean vaz
washington l'insinuation selon laquelle
nous essayons d'étouffer le peuple
tigréens en refusant l'accès humanitaire
et en utilisant la fin comme arme de
guerre est invraisemblable millions de
paires justice il n'y a absolument
aucune raison pour que nous le fassions
tout doucement le conflit a déjà fait
des milliers de morts dans le nord du
pays la population en est la première
victime prise en étau entre les deux
camps addis abeba rejette toute
possibilité de dialogue avec les
dirigeants du groupe rebelle classée
organisation terroriste en mai dernier
par le parlement éthiopien la communauté
internationale de son côté tente
d'intervenir mais l'onu prévoit une
détérioration de la situation
la question restant de savoir jusqu'à
quel point et à quelle vitesse les
talibans poursuivent leur offensive en
afghanistan ils se sont emparés dans la
journée dans districts clés dans la
province de kandahar
l'armée afghane se retrouve de plus en
plus seuls face aux insurgés car les
troupes militaires étrangères a honte
entamé leur retrait du pays
fin août les derniers soldats américains
auront quitté l'afghanistan
yamina menda à quel d'art dans le nord
du pays
à quelques pas de l'ouzbékistan et du
tadjikistan c'est armé que les forces
gouvernementales associées à des milices
avance à la recherche des talibans les
traces du passage des insurgés sont
encore visibles
comme vous le voyez c'est une maison
privée
les talibans sont venus et ont creusé
chaque murs des maisons dans le but d'y
pénétrer dans cette zone
regardez voici un endroit où les
talibans ont attaqué à l'armé lourde
nous sommes arrivés ici vers 6h hier
alors que le quartier général de la
sécurité et le district était capturé
par les talibans
le bazar du district a également été
capturé par les talibans qui nous ont
combattu pendant deux heures et non pas
plus nous vaincre ce qui les a poussés à
se retirer
les talibans se serait emparé de plus de
40 district ces dernières semaines ils
contrôleraient plus d'une centaine de
district sur 400 il existe d'autres
districts dont seul le centre et détenu
par l'administration de kaboul
mais les zones environnantes sont sous
notre contrôle
donc on le calcule en tous ces plus de
80% du territoire qui est tenu par nos
forces
prise en étau dans ce conflit meurtrier
les familles menacées quittent leur
domicile
cela fait environ 3 à 4 jours que nous
dormons ici sur le sol et mes enfants
qui sont ici aussi
enfin n'ont pas d'eau potable et pas de
nourriture à manger
nous dormons dans ce froid et cela fait
deux jours que nous n'avons ni
nourriture ni eau nous ne recevons que
des dîners il n'y a plus rien à manger
notre maison a été bombardées et
détruites j'ai été déplacées mon mari a
été martyrisé j'espère que le
gouvernement me donnera une maison de la
nourriture ils doivent nous donner un
abri
ces attaques de taliban lieu alors que
le retrait progressif de l'armée
américaine et de l'otan se poursuit
mardi l'allemagne a déclaré que ses
troupes avaient quitté le pays
même annonce le lendemain de la part de
l'italie particulièrement engagés sur
place avec 58 militaires déployés en 20
ans le pentagone lui relativise pour joe
biden un accord de paix entre les
talibans et le gouvernement afghan est
envisageable une paix qu'il présente
comme l'ultime solution pour rétablir
l'ordre dans le pays
égoutter nous sommes dans cette guerre
depuis vingt ans vingt ans j'ai
rencontré le gouvernement afghan ici à
la maison blanche dans le bureau ovale
je pense que les talibans sont en mesure
de soutenir le gouvernement
il va y avoir en cours de route d'autres
négociations je suppose mais ce qui
m'intéresse c'est petit souk de l'or
problème interne afin de générer au
soutien national d'autres ils ont besoin
pour maintenir le gouvernement les
etats-unis ont annoncé leur intention
d'achever le retrait des troupes
américaines engagées en afghanistan
d'ici la fin du mois prochain
c'est la fin de cette édition prochains
jours malin à 21h à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative au sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que ces normes